哈囉 歡迎來到思想實驗室
我是國威
今天我們要聊的這本書
AI創世紀
是一本蠻矛盾的書
它的作者有三位
領頭的是這一位
操盤冷戰的地緣政治大師
季辛吉
最近已經過世了
還有前Google的執行長
施密特
還有前微軟的高管蒙迪
老實說這三位為什麼會湊在一起
把這些AI作為
我們現代生活中
已經脫離不了的一部分
造成這樣子局面的人
簡直就像是賣毒品的人
突然寫了一本生存大說帖
來警告我們
甚至警告全世界的人
告訴大家說
小心啊
這個東西會摧毀人類文明
那這三位可以說是掌握過
全球政治以及
科技霸權方向盤的頂層精英
透過這本書
來聯手呼籲全世界
要注意AI失控這個問題
這到底是科技巨頭
為了要規避責任
鞏固霸權
寫的這個脫罪宣言
還是有其他的意思呢
今天我們邀請到一位
非常特別的來賓
來跟我們探討這個議題
讓我們來歡迎
前LINE臺灣總經理
現在的企業AI創新顧問
陶韻智先生
各位好
各位觀眾聽眾大家好
陶總你好
我現在稱呼您陶總
這樣會不會怪怪的
還是您喜歡用
我英文名字是Sting
久仰Sting很久
那今天真的很高興
能透過這本書的機會
邀請您來上我們節目
有一個很有趣的事
就是您跟這本書裡面的
兩位作者
一位是施密特
一位是蒙迪
其實有一個類似的背景
你同樣待過
這個跨國的科技巨頭
待了蠻長的時間
見證了產品從無到有
而且是爆發性的成長
變成一個跨國的服務這樣子
自己呢
其實也寫了這個書
AI First 自我升級革命
因為AI的關係
現在這整個流程
都變得比較簡單
其實我很好奇
您可不可以先跟我講一下
你覺得矽谷大佬
然後他們現在瘋狂的
包括施密特在內
他還投資了很多
國防AI科技的創業
他還投資了很多這樣的公司
火箭科技他也投資了
你覺得他們現在在瘋狂砸錢
搞AI武器競賽
然後又出了這本書
寫法很像要呼籲各國的領導者
去敬畏AI
去小心AI會帶來的事情
他們到底腦子在想什麼
我自己用AI
從去年二月ALL IN之後
AI升級了我的
過去已經還不錯的經驗
大概升級了一百倍到一千倍
從我自己對AI的看法
我也敬畏了
第二個
我想用AI創造無比的商機
對我自己 例如說
我如果自己用原來的方式做
也許我可以去創業帶一群人
然後做出一種機率上可能幾個百分比
然後達到一個更厲害的
這個回報的結果對不對
可是有AI之後
我覺得我的這種想法的風險性
降低了
我出手的次數可以多
差不多一萬倍吧
剛才一百一千倍
我聽起來就已經是
能力上的一百一千倍
但是我出手次數
因為你出手就要花錢
我現在出手
我現在已經寫過一千多個軟體了
What
那我出手的次數
決定了我可不可以參與遊戲
我自己感受到的就是AI超級強
它改變了非常多社會的做事方法
過去不管成功的方程式也好
施密特他在矽谷
他們在這些科技巨頭在矽谷
看到的應該是我看到的一千倍吧
像Fable 5 暫時被封
它又出來了
說要透過一些審核可以用
Fable 5出來的時候
我立刻下去寫了一個程式
你掌握那三天
我掌握那三天
馬上完成一個
我之前用其他模型
都做不出來的東西
就是那個用Google AI Studio
它可以打打字
然後右邊就出現Preview
就是東西看起來很好用
我也想做一個這種
所見即所得Coding Tool
你不只是要做那個App
你還要做一個Coding Tool
我不只是想要用它的Coding Tool
我想要自己做Coding Tool
我之前已經嘗試了大概幾十次了
只要有模型
我有各種模型
那結果Fable 5一出來
我就做完了
所以我現在有像Google AI Studio
我自己的Coding Tool
可能過幾天
我再把它在臉書上去公佈
那這個Fable 5一做出來
我就想 哇 超爽 超強
這麼強的東西不用管制嗎
或者這麼強的東西
我是個優異的商人
或我是個惡劣的商人
我都想要全力的擁抱它嗎
不管我要做好事還是做壞事
再來 那AI的能力僅止於此嗎
如果我手上是有RD的
有研發資源的
我就會想
那當然要把它推向人類福祉
一個東西好跟壞
常常兩個都可能發生
好的地方
它可以讓我做出Coding Tool
我可以讓我的組織
都有我們喜歡用的Coding Tool
因為Google AI Studio
它有些事沒做
例如說
部署上Cloudflare它沒做
它做的是部署上Google雲端
那我要把它一鍵部署到Cloudflare
我就把它做完
矽谷這邊一直狂砸錢
因為這個技術還沒看到邊緣
還是應該要發展
為了整體人類福祉
可是同時間就注意到
它反過來可能會造成負面的事情
這麼強的東西
如果在一個所謂的壞人的手裡
那會發生什麼事
世界總是好人跟壞人在打架
老實說
我們看我們現在社會
壞人是靠什麼方式去管制他的
是靠警察
那現在是因為警察制度
賦予他打人的權利
限制別人自由的權利
AI這個級別的所謂的能力
不是只是石頭的能力
丟石頭砸人
它可能是核彈的能力
他看到了
其實我也看到了
那這個時候兩個track都做
一個track是盡可能的發展
增加未來人類生活的福祉
另外一方面就是
儘可能的避免它被誤用
例如說黑道集團掌握
人手一顆核彈
那我不是很麻煩嗎
那所以這時候就限制你的自由
想辦法在這上面做出一個方法
讓壞事不發生 只發生好事
那我覺得這是這本書在做的事情
因為你接觸AI的關係
你深刻的感覺到這些人
無敵強
他們內心的恐懼
一定很恐懼
我看到都覺得害怕了
接下去老實說
半年之後的世界長什麼樣
我都沒有辦法預測了
包括我們自己在做很多的內容
特別是內容相關技術的演進
更是讓我們很害怕
就是可能三個月之後按一個鍵
我們這個Podcast也不用錄了
就兩個人就跑出來就錄完了
這個恐懼我覺得蠻合理的
這本書它一直不斷在強調說
AI的力量會超越傳統的民族國家
然後呼籲政府要建立類似
國際原子能總署
這樣子的機構來嚴格監管AI
可是現在的情況是
這些AI的算力
還有資料以及人才
這些東西其實都捏在
包括施密特跟蒙迪
他們的老東家手上
就是Google 微軟等等這些公司
我們也知道這些矽谷的公司
絕大多數都是矽谷的公司
美國的公司
他們其實現在連歐盟的法規
都不太想遵守
都不斷使盡方式去遊說
希望說不要管那麼多
可是這些人現在又在主動要求被監管
這個其實讓我有點摸不著頭緒
他們現在到底想怎樣
有一個可能性
是我也聽很多人提過
就是他們想要藉由
某種監管的策略
也就是某種所謂的護城河策略
設定一個超高門檻的國際法規
透過這樣的方式
這些門檻只有這些超級大公司跨得過去
這樣子就可以把其他想要做AI的一些小公司
就稍微能跟他們有機會比拼的公司
全部都封殺掉
包括其他的小國家也都封殺掉
是讓美國獨尊
他讓美國獨霸
你覺得是這個目的嗎
我覺得第一個
肯定不是這個目的
目前所謂的AI到底誰有
現在所謂的前沿的AI
Frontier的AI是厲害的
那Frontier AI最強的當然在美國
那是因為資本的關係
但他也沒有限制任何人研發
有在AI裡面算得上
在前幾名的國家大概有
美國 中國 歐洲的法國
他有Mistral AI
然後日本也有自己做模型
最近有聽到一個Sakana AI
其實他不是只有美國有
只是說美國的花的錢最多
裡面有資料的收集 人才的彙集
他不是你想做就做
事實上我們沒有限制臺灣不能做
沒有 沒有任何人限制
之所以不能做是因為我們科學家太少
AI科學家
美國跟中國加起來大概就全世界的
AI科學家了
所以是這個原因
我們做不出前沿的
監管這件事
在前兩年的時候
其實AI一起來
歐盟馬上就出法規了
對 歐盟出的法規就是
注意喔
不能收集喔 不能講錯話
講錯話我要罰你錢喔
你每次上線前我都要審查喔
民族國家的人
尤其是歐盟這種
他出法規
韓國也有加入
技術做不過你
我們在監管上做得過你可以了吧
監管其實是全世界的共識
只是歐盟做完之後
窒礙難行
其實當時的模型跟
現在的Open模型的性能還比不上
前沿模型之外
其實Open模型到處都有
要拿都拿得到
歐盟在一兩年前就已經制定法規了
只是窒礙難行
那他們也自己鬆綁
否則AI完全無法進步
所以這裡有兩個事
一個是進步 一個是規定
把它管制起來
進步管制保護人類
保護隱私避免濫用
這兩條都是在持續進步的
那美國呢
他在法規上蠻晚做的
因為他們注意到
如果管的話不能進步了
這不就是因為他們內部這些企業
都一直努力在遊說
然後一直在互相的拉扯
我們再看幾個
中國沒有在管
連談都沒有談
那美國呢是說
那你那邊的模型我去要審查
那我不去了
因為反正我們這邊沒規定
那也許我這邊有遊說
歐盟呢一開始做就管
所以他們就發展不出來
美國呢他看的很明顯
是看他的敵人沒有管
他管的話
顯然會有問題
能夠做這種花這麼大錢的國家
全世界也蠻多可以花錢的 對吧
人才除了臺灣比較少之外
歐洲總是也有
DeepMind就在英國
傾歐洲整個歐盟之力
找幾個AI科學家是可以做到的
但他法規先行
所以那邊反而應該要遊說
事實上他們也遊說了
一直講延後六個月實施
再延後六個月實施
所以他們終究還出了一個模型
例如說以hacker的角度
因為現在全世界的所有的科技
大概都運作在軟體上面
軟體一定有Bug
結果最新最強的模型
他可以瞬間找出來
你每一個網站的Bug
那這時候就會可以進行攻擊
那我們的整個Infrastructure就會出問題
目前美國的模型大概領先
中國的模型 開放模型
六個月到八個月
只有六個月到八個月
那以後呢
這模型很強的時候
如果人人都可以用
裡面有一個比例是壞人
就會越來越難抓
所以這裡顯然要管制
沖天炮不用管制
核彈要管制
瓦斯爐不用管制 但是
這個原子能要管制
有很多東西要管制
這就是群體生活後
人會自己發展出來的規則
我們說好
譬如說像國際原子能總署
他也就是很像聯合國底下的
這樣子相關的單位
這種國際組織
一旦這些制定權力的規則
老實說現在也都落在
這幾家巨頭的顧問團手中
因為其實你看現在開什麼世界大會
OpenAI Anthropic Google Meta
都是這些代表坐在那邊 對不對
那像臺灣這種小國
我們除了
我們的下場是不是就是只有在
AI封建時代裡面當農奴
雖然說我們現在好像整個經濟
因為AI硬體的關係而發展的不錯
但是就如您所說
其實我們沒有能力去制定這個規則
我們Fable 5要禁掉
臺灣也是禁了
我們也沒有辦法用
那我們自己也沒有先進的模型
那臺灣接下來
我們有什麼上桌談判的資格嗎
人類歷史活了五千年八千年
都是朝越來越好的方向前進
我們目前生活每一個人
即便是乞丐
過得應該都比秦始皇還好
秦始皇是當時最強的人
但是他去山東要花一個月
死掉回來
不能夠發LINE傳給 說我死了
全國都不知道他死了
還可以搞一個鬧劇出來
現在的生活跟以前生活完全不一樣
我也毫不猶豫的相信
我女兒的生活
十五年後的生活
她會過得比巴菲特今天還好
巴菲特今天生活中的
旁邊的一切 便利性
我認為我女兒在十五年
三十年後的生活
一定比她過得還好
那事實上我看最新的是
我們可以去Amazon去申請
Fable 5的使用權
他會問你要拿來幹嘛
現在他又開放了
但他一定會有些人他不給他申請
我覺得不如
我把他想成選邊站
我要我的生活型態的這一邊
然後我去跟他申請他就會同意
因為我們講的話一樣
我要做科學研究
那他可能就會給我用
沒有喔
我想要去控制無人機
打別人喔
那就不給你用
那這時候可能說
那我們是被他管轄的嗎
不如說人本來就是群居的動物
你就是跟同意識型態的人在一起
然後分工
我們就加入自由民主陣營
然後一起把全世界搞好
我們做晶片製造
你就做這個
每個模型都花十億美金
一直燒一直燒
我燒不起
或者我不想燒
我不想培養這種人
但是我培養了硬體制造的人
目前你如果反過來看這句話的意思就是
全世界都是
晶片的封建時代的農奴
因為我們已經把晶片製造
整個給它壟斷了
那從他角度
他也可以講那句話
但事實上我們是合作的
臺灣把美國的晶片產業偷走了
偷走了嘛
然後這個時候就說
那我們是農奴
其實那個有時候政治語言跟真的語言是兩回事
全世界一定是
截長補短各取所需
比較利益法則在運作的
我覺得今天這樣子的配合是蠻好的
施密特他們寫這本書
我覺得背後有一個
如果非我族類
則完全要把它
楚河漢界這樣
隔開
因為我無法預期你明天會做什麼事
我想他可以預期我臺灣會做什麼事
但他無法預期
例如說
伊朗會做什麼事
這時候看起來就很暴力
就是 你把他打
你有沒有人性
不對 為了我們這一邊
的未來生活型態
我們的意識型態
我們相信的道理
例如說就是可以投票的道理
你那邊咧 怎麼樣
我可以尊重你
不過看起來
如果你有這麼強大的武器
你會影響我的意識型態
遲則變敵人
這樣的管制
在這樣的基礎下就非常的好
我們就拿施密特來說好了
那他其實掌權Google蠻久的
那現在雖然是前CEO的角色
那但是我們也都知道
Google的使命是彙整全球資訊
那但是呢
施密特他自己在這本書裡面
在AI創世紀裡面就承認了
現在AI 已經變成
無法解釋的Oracle了
Oracle就是神諭
老實說他可以給你答案
但是你不懂他的邏輯
那這個所謂的黑盒子的比喻呢
我們在很多地方都看得到
然後很多的大師也都這樣講
這就是這個AI的現況這樣子
那如果說現在連全世界
可能號稱最懂數據的公司的前CEO呢
都承認他們現在其實
已經搞不懂AI了
那這種情況之下
到底怎麼樣去對抗這些虛假的訊息
或是說做所謂的監管呢
因為他裡面給的這些建議
是不是就會變成其實是沒有意義的呢
客觀真相這件事情就已經消失了嘛
那這些建議會不會他都變成只是
說好聽話
就是說大家要注意一下
但是大家也無能為力這種感覺
目前當然會有很多末日敘事
或者說又有很多這種滑坡謬誤
滑坡謬誤
AI很強
而且沒有人知道AI是怎麼想事情的
AI很強 所以人都會相信它
所以假的也會相信它
然後人們會特別相信AI
以後呢我如果要選舉
那麼我就乾脆去買通AI
或者是我去做一個AI
對啊
因為假設接下來
什麼連民意調查啊
連什麼選民的意見啊
老實說現在大家都漸漸用AI了
我們都可以預期這些事情
就很快會滲入到這些層面上
那是不是大家就
透過這個AI在作為我們所有人的中介
那事實上就厲害的人
他只要能夠搞定這個AI
然後民主就被毀掉了
先講我對人性的信心
如果我們可以在節目上討論這個題目的話
就代表所有社會學家
所有的政治家
所有的民眾
他大概也都會提這個題目
然後人們就會意識到他可能有問題
然後就會討論
就會研究如何透過
不管是法律呢 還是教育呢
教育是最基本的
就提升人們的素養
那它是AI
它講的話很有道理
那我們要做什麼
我們要做有智慧的選擇
你可以請它告訴你
做這一題的五百個有道理的理由
然後我們要把人教會
評估這五百個很棒的理由
挑一個適合我的答案
其實我們在挑答案的時候
所謂的聽啊 相信
它是一個perspective的問題
例如從收入角度看
我覺得你的政見很有道理
從我要完成我小孩從小長到大
我要花的錢的角度
我覺得你的政見有道理
我現在很有錢了
所以我不看錢
我看的是我們國家競爭力
那競爭力的話我就爽
我想要我們地位提高
這樣我出去外國的時候我比較爽
好 在這樣子的perspective下
我覺得第三個人講的比較有道理
其實選道理的時候
都是根據它一定有一些前提
有假設的前提 有事實的前提
我們不會希望我們的國民呢
是在道理上是盲目的
所以這透過教育去
增加他的批判性思考力
不管AI多強
其實它就是一個提供意見的工具
人類不可能把選項就交給AI
自動化處理那個選項
如果那個選項是很重要的選項
是不會給他的
現在空調調28度
因為這樣比較舒服
等一下調25度
因為這一題沒有那麼重要
就讓AI管
但是明天我小孩能不能上這個高中
他後來的人生怎麼樣
最後那一步一定是我決定
我們想多一點
因為現在有很多人就被詐騙
詐到傾家蕩產
我覺得那些東西還蠻重要的
但是有很多人就是這樣被詐騙
那只要幾個percentage
我們也不要說全民都被這樣詐騙
但是有幾個percentage的人
有幾個百分比的人
能夠因為人家設計的訊息
能夠因為這樣廣泛的演算法的曝光
讓他跌入這樣陷阱
難道我們比人頭比選票的民主政治
就不會陷入同樣的問題嗎
正如我們其實在臺灣也看到
其實好像有很多的選舉
它的結果就已經有開始這種有徵兆了
選戰已經到科技戰
到這種社群輿論戰
選舉就一人一票
所以很多人在hacker這個系統
那我們現在主要是講裡面
如果是不真實的部分
先講詐騙好了
詐騙在沒有AI出現跟有AI出現都有詐騙
詐騙基本上是一個心理學
因為人有confirmation bias(確認偏誤)
他就相信這是真的
然後就相信
在科技的推波助瀾下
他更容易接觸到那個
然後我們可以達到
更廣的confirmation bias的人
那你只要一直塑造
在他旁邊都說這件事是真的
然後他就相信
以至於造成詐騙的事實
可是詐騙永遠克服的方法是什麼
那就是讓更多的資訊更自由的流通
教育他說
你如果看到這個
你先想基本事實
年報酬300%
理由是什麼
那我用AI的方式去推波助瀾
讓你旁邊的假帳號出現一大堆
出現成功案例
然後讓你相信這個敘事
那也很正常
因為我沒有AI都會成功的
我有AI只是強化他
那再來解決方法就是
A吃藥跟B考上大學
本來就是兩回事
的這個基礎素養
是我們要持續做的
然後也要持續的宣傳他
然後接下來
警察的巡邏
也是我們持續在做的
就是看到有人跟他講說
開始講這個話的時候
然後把他抓起來說
你不要再跟他講話了
你不要再聽他的
我們把他阻止
或者整個管制系統
也用AI去強化
道高一尺 魔高一丈
但是我們永遠要追上最新科技
對
但是如果說我們
講到政治的層面
他就好像沒有詐騙那麼可以
相對的是非分明這樣子
譬如說政治的操弄
他可能在演算法上面是很
很隱晦的
這個國家是可以去檢查
那個演算法
我們可以去請那個公司
提出來你演算法的基礎
應該要這麼做
像我以前在LINE工作
你做平臺的第一要務
是保護用戶
我們To C的
用戶覺得有利的
我們一定全做
包括你就喜歡看這個
我就一直給你看這個
這叫平臺的之所以存在的意義
可是平臺想要長治久安的經營的話
我們也很重要的是
那你這個國家有沒有規定什麼
你規定什麼我就做什麼
遵守當地法規
因為這樣我才能賺錢
以商業角度看
我是儘量滿足用戶的需求
我就會賺錢
我儘量滿足法規的需求
所以這時候
你應該給我一個法規
當我們有遇到一些問題
然後政府就出了一些法規給我
這樣我就很好做了
因為我們並不是想找任何人麻煩
只是如果沒法規
我們就是用戶資料保護法
我們就不會去做別的
因為我們不是法律執行者
法律一定是當地國家共識後
Minimum的Requirement會進到法律
可是 我們如果在做平臺的時候
我們不負責做警察的工作
除非你給我一道指令
我覺得現在就是
國家如果他有一個
人民的共識
人民共識的Minimum Requirement
就是法規
那那個法規就會變成
平臺遵循的工具
要把這個改變其實很簡單
就是改法律
那在民主國家改法律當然很困難
但是你不改法律
就不用談說我要操弄你
我覺得我們平臺沒有要操弄任何東西
是因為沒有法規規定我
那我就用這個叫Free Speech
我覺得剛才好像
提出了一個解決方案
但是必須要說我還是會感覺蠻危險的
因為畢竟假設我們現在每天
看的這個不管是手機
或各個螢幕上面的這些App
其實差不多幾個
上面的演算法基本上也感覺就是
這幾個大公司在決定
這幾個頂層的演算法
大概要用什麼樣的邏輯在設計
感覺其實
我們要有辦法去要求
譬如說包括臺灣在內
我們有沒有辦法去要求FaceBook
要求Google 包括LINE
然後提出說
你解釋解釋你的演算法
其實就是可以
真的是可以
你只要是有法規
你是過立法院的法規
例如說中國好了
中國的RUN的平臺
出現敏感字不是會不見嗎
因為那有法規
那同一個系統
它在臺灣出現的時候
那個字就出現了
為什麼那家公司沒事要做兩套法規
因為他想賺錢
通常問題是在哪裡
新東西出來
政府部門跟定法律的部門
瞭解得太慢
廣告詐騙那麼多
這時候我們就會說
你就是臉書要賺錢
我其實研究過這個問題
我其實常常聽這種講話
我就想我若是臉書
我應該不會想要詐騙者
在我這邊下廣告
因為我以前LINE就深蒙其害
我來準確描述
事實上這整個鏈
國家一定要做事
例如我要查他身份好了
可能是不可以查 對吧
你為什麼可以查 你誰啊
那他如果拿了一個看起來合法的文件
我只好信了
然後我只好讓他
信用卡看起來OK
其實他是偷來信用卡
我就只好讓他付錢
因為你又沒有規定
我有權利去查他
回去查
還有我可以拒絕他嗎
我拒絕他違反公平待客
你又會告我
那你就說準一點
壞人你把他擋起來
好人你不要擋
天啊他有白手套在後面
我有那麼懂嗎
後面那麼多層
我怎麼知道他是好人還是壞人
不小心我就想
好算了
我為了保護大家
我真的做過
誤殺一個對不對
誤殺一個好人
那個就告到消保官去了
真的
因為我就違反了消費者保護法
因為他說我歧視他
其實我們有很多要follow的法規
我不是說這很不好
我是說這非常好
詐騙裡面有非常多生態系
他要有一個人下廣告
然後那個圖片要有一個來源
那接下來他導到的網頁要有一個來源
假設那個地方是一個平臺
那個平臺註冊者有一個來源
然後那個來源有一個IP
那那個IP有一個什麼
我要抓 怎麼會抓不到
像貨已經到我們家了對不對
我們不是會跟他講
到貨付款 我就給他錢
結果錢就跑走了
裡面是空的
這件事的後面就是
那誰寄這個貨
就抓那個人就好
可是臺灣在這裡有非常多斷點
你應該規定我說
那如果他是
不是臺灣的IP 都不可以用
不過你只要講這句話
大概會違反民主法治自由的原則
所以法律那裡訂的好
或者說所謂的訂的有共識
通常會花蠻久時間的
不過這值得去努力
瞭解
尤其在這次的AI上面
我們是擔心那個AI會造成的
很糟糕的結果
那我們現在可以做的
先從法律著手
而法律如果在民主國家的話
其實這個鑰匙掌握在我們手上
而且要過立法院
其實是掌握在立法院手裡
那立法院是人民選出來的
反映了人們
人民的常識
那所以整個常識提高
我們會對這些Lawmaker
的要求會再提高
法律就是全民共識的底線
所以在我們的國家
是不會出現刪除言論自由
字眼那種字
我們的法律不可能出那個
那我們會出什麼
我們在禁止那個人
放廣告的時候
我們的理由是什麼
這是需要思辨的
最後我想要問一個根本的問題
Sting現在也在教很多的人
包括企業 利用vibe coding也好
Agentic Coding也好
出嘴寫程式 操控你的Agent
雖然說這本書是一年多前
英文版就出了
其實他們因為看得很遠
所以都預判了一些
包括我們此時此刻
以及接下來幾年可能發生的事情
比如說他指出
AI可以在幾天之內發現新的抗生素
這個很多新的療法
然後超越人類科學家可能幾百年的努力
這已經不是開玩笑的
因為大家也知道AlphaFold
它能夠去預測這個蛋白質的折疊
基本上它就已經減少了
真的是不知道幾百年
如果真的要靠人力的這件事情
提高了很多的效率
但是科學似乎漸漸的
從理解世界變成了
向AI這個黑盒子去許願
你說outcome base
那我們的下一代呢
他就是對AI去問一些好問題
他就得到他要的東西了
那他們還會覺得說
我要去辛苦的學習微積分
學習物理邏輯嗎
我們會不會培養出一代科技文盲
他其實是不知其所依然
而這個會讓你擔心嗎
我不會擔心
我一點也不擔心
我們現在尤其是亞洲
甚至就是臺灣
我們的學習方式是有徹底的問題的
我們所謂的學習微積分
就是學習那些算式
我是如果以科目上來說
他們有告訴我當初怎麼發明的
拿沙子去計算面積
然後給它切
例如說這條線底下的面積 怎麼算
石頭丟到圈子裡面
切一切
看丟幾個石頭
一顆石頭是多少
所以極限的去加總算出來它的面積
那個過程怎麼來的
是因為問了一個WHY
我為什麼要這個面積
我為什麼要這種形狀的面積
那這樣想跟那樣想
我們缺什麼工具去把它完成
沒有工具可不可以發明一個工具
所以發明了微積分
我們現在的學生的教法是
我其實不知道為什麼要那個弧的面積
我也不想知道
我只想做
當你給我一個弧我就把它算出來
算出來幹嘛
今天如果有另外一個人可以算
你為什麼要算
你真正要了解的是
弧為什麼要算
好 那現在再往下想
假設我在太空中
想要去算一個
立體的不規則形狀的某種體積
假設目前的數學工具做不出來
那你要怎麼做
我還是想要算出那個體積
然後去算我的數據中心放上去的時候
可以產生多少電
可以產生多少算力回來
結果少了工具
那要不要發明工具 要
發明工具還是開始從為什麼
這是第一點
第二點是 所謂的我以前學的到底是什麼
我以前小時候學過珠算
我想大家都學過珠算
算盤算一算
老祖宗的智慧
這個智慧
我想到今天
應該沒有任何一個人同意
這件事對我有任何意義吧
因為它就是一個
為了解帳務問題
然後說這個加這個等於多少
他想要快一點的算出來
所以就拿了一個算盤
應該沒有任何一個人是拿珠算
在算我們分錢的時候該怎麼分
一定是拿iPhone手機起來
那這樣子就是科技文盲嗎
我覺得這是科技的
literacy很高的人
正確的使用方法
這些工具
有它時代背景
可是更值得一學的是
人們有的是對問題的好奇心
以及不懈的問問題的方法
如果你無法解決問題
你最好發明一個新工具
而不是再去問
有沒有既有工具可以做
那都只要既有工具的
大概都是既有答案
既有答案 交給一臺運算機
computer算就好了
何必我算
我再講最後一個
我記得我老師
後來我臺大物理的老師
我遇到他 他是這麼說
他說AI出來
讓一些數學不好的人可以做研究了
我只是不會算數學
那通常怎麼做
你就找一個數學家合作
經過很努力的半天之後
終於得到輝煌的結果
以前天文物理學界有很多這個故事
他們要找
就是那時候很多女性是
人類computer
在算微積分
就是要負責讓他們處理這些 算的事情
所以今天
我就可以做我的物理研究
然後我的數學 交給AI算
反正我就不會
解一個複雜的未來性的問題的話
需要很多的技能
我覺得今天是
讓人們再往前推到更前沿
我們終於可以從傳統
從一加一等於二
學到微積分
學到可能高等微積分的
這個繁複的
可能十年的學習過程
都還沒產生任何成果
直接縮短
你就來好奇
古時候的人
我說希臘那個時候的人
或者是牛頓那個時期的人
他們都是多才多藝的
他就好奇 他什麼都可以問
當時沒有那麼多書要讀
他就發明 發明 發明
我覺得現在是一個大發現時代
又要來了
那不如這樣
我們應該教的就是
你應該發現 你應該觀察
你應該看題目 越難的越好
他可以幫你算數學
他可以幫你看物理
他可以幫你設計實驗
所謂的發問就好
當然你發問的過程
只要當他答案回來的時候
你就進步了
你的盲點就被縮小了
你其實變成一個非常博學的人
所以真正的問題是
大家還沒有
start from why
像Vibe Coding
我在教的都是
所以你要做什麼
當大家都想來學一個工具
十分鐘學完
好像是解決既有的工作這樣子
那你去做既有工作
那你原來的工作
你可不可以再增加十倍
Why你要用Vibe Coding tool
因為你有一個十倍產值要增加
Why你要來學
因為我想要做十件
我從來不會做的事
但是我覺得我很想做
那你就來用這個做
因為用你原來的方法
你一定做不出來
那用這個方法
你可以做出來
這輩子就做出來
這輩子
這一個月就做出來
你不用瞭解他
寫程式
我要從Hello, World!開始學
為什麼要
因為以前我們都這樣學
所以呢
那為什麼要
因為你如果不這樣
你不能瞭解每一個code
為什麼要看code
我真正要的是
那個商業問題被我解決
所以今天我們有好工具出來了
你就不應該去河邊洗衣服
你就應該用洗衣機
毫不猶豫的使用洗衣機
其實我也常有這樣的感覺
就是我覺得很多人在
一邊在擔心
人們會沒有工作做
另外一邊在擔心
年輕人會沒有學習的機會
眼睜睜的確看到
所謂剷馬糞的工作
或是把這本書
印十份這種工作消失了
以致於 那他們就沒有鍛鍊的機會了
可是鍛鍊那個要幹嘛
對對對 反過來就是說
那其實是因為我們現在
想得不夠遠
我們現在還沒有去解決
你要如何在月球
建立一個殖民地呢
對
你要如何在地球跟火星之間
建立基地呢
就是我們還沒有去想
這種程度的問題的時候
我們就會很擔心沒有工作做
對
如果要殖民月球要做的事好多
因為現在感覺是
原本覺得完全不會去想像
可以做到的事情
我覺得我們很缺這個事情
就是去想像
那些我原本可能完全
做不到的事情
我們一直在想
困在自己原本在做的事情
那AI當然就一直在取代
我們原本可以做的事情
本來就取代了
對啊
但我覺得這個 很難
我覺得這反而是難的事情
所以我們在這個年代
我們應該高興是
我們看過第一次工業革命
第二次工業革命 第三次工業革命
我們現在在第四次工業革命的開頭
我們就是歷史
可能十年後看課本裡面就會說
當年你們那群人
我們這群人 對著電腦 按東按西
讀很多資料 為了做一個簡報
花了兩個禮拜
那個年代是這樣
然後那時候的孫女就說
你們真有意思
我們現在都用講的
他就做出來了
而且只要兩分鐘
爺爺 你花了兩個禮拜
怎麼不用這個呢
那我們現在 還看不到那個未來
但是 你如果用想的
每一次你都會去想以前
蛤 你們要到河邊洗衣服
那個水不會很髒嗎
這不會很遠嗎 你不會流汗嗎
你為什麼不用洗衣機
可是第一個用洗衣機的人是誰
是我們這個時候要想的事
最後不是思想實驗
但我想問Sting
就是說 你覺得你五年之後會在做什麼
因為我以前好像可以看得到
現在我已經看不到了
對 因為我現在老實說
連兩個月之後的世界是怎麼樣
我都看不到
半年之後的公司會長什麼樣子
我漸漸已經看不到
那其實這對於公司經營
或是說對一個這個中年人來說
我覺得我都還蠻惶恐
我很想知道Sting
你現在還會以一個CEO的視野
去看很遠的事情嗎
還是說你現在是有點
活在當下的感覺
如果真實來說的話
即便是在LINE的工作位置上
我都看不到一年後的事
這是實際上的
也不是我在謙虛或無能
我蠻有能力的
當然 當然
可是在LINE裡面
社長告訴我們的都是只看三個月
在IBM第一份工作的時候
公司裡面叫我們看三年
第一個我在想
可能是一個意識型態的問題
是到底是誰跟你說可以看五年
因為我們看過的勵志書
都告訴我們要看五年
對
對吧 那我如果不聽他的不就得了嗎
因為我聽了我們LINE社長之後
我更成功 他叫我看三個月
後來我們談話他就說
我就問你一個月可不可以做出來
然後就說 可是這要鋪陳
因為你拿你第一份工作的話去講
你就要跟他講三年
老闆你有問題
再第二個回答就是
那我按我現在的人生智慧來講
我就抓變跟不變的
那不變的就是
五年後我還是要活得更快樂
更有錢 更有影響力
變的就是現在的技術
它可以幫我把這一條軌跡
去做得比較好
更快樂這個是一個大目標
那快樂里面我們就拆分
可能看到更多的人
去被影響到的話
那我會很高興
看起來我只有在臺灣影響這些人
那我可不可以在美國影響這些人
隨時都不放棄這些目標
這些目標如果達到了
那我會很高興
然後在這五年中就一直變
也就是用一個月三個月
一直在變來變去
但是不變的是
每一個單項的選擇
我都是為了五年後的
那一個目標在做
以我為例
我當下一定有很多選擇
去找一個總經理工作
想辦法做三年 把錢賺一賺
那這樣就達成錢的目標
可是不會達成快樂的目標
也不會達成影響力的目標
所以這時候在手上的幾個選項中
去臺大教個書好了
那這樣子好像有達成這個目標
但沒達成另外一個目標
可是另外一個目標
我用別的東西來做就好了
所以每一個選擇
可能都是一個月三個月
六個月內可做的
看很遠沒什麼用
我要成為一個新創公司
十億美金的市值的老闆
他的不確定性太高
他檢驗的標準就只有一個
就是三年後是或不是
然後全部的時間都不快樂
那我就不會做這個選擇
最後一個當然就是那會惶恐
我是沒有惶恐
我即使沒達到也不會惶恐
真正的原因是因為
惶恐也沒有辦法增加我的表現
研究所的時候老師告訴我這件事
然後我就一直把它背起來
一直在參透這件事
我後來就理解
這實在太有道理了
我害怕所以我會成功嗎
我擔心等一下會表現不好
所以等一下我會表現好嗎
只要這樣反問自己
那幾個動作都沒有用的時候
我連講都不會講
其實絕大部分人都不是真的
看到了未來我的做法是不work的
他只是不知道哪裡來的意識型態
讓他理解 他得先知道答案
他得往標準答案方向前進
他得好像知道 先看到未來
然後他就會很佩服說
陶總那你很大膽
我說我其實就是膽小的
因為膽小才會去改
如果我用我原來的路徑走到三年後
我去年不做AI的話
我認為我三年後一定會被淘汰
因為怕變那樣
所以我就all in AI
all in AI的方法是什麼
開始做
不懂怎麼辦
再做
然後做了還不懂
懂了更做
爽了之後
賺錢
提高影響力
沒有影響力
所以這個邏輯上就是
自洽的
而裡面所有的情緒的那些字眼
我覺得是 在想要成為頂尖人士中
都沒有意義的句子
瞭解
今天真的非常謝謝Sting
除了透過這本書
也透過AI創世紀
透過這本AI創世紀
三位算是
他們是真正的大師
我相信他們也有過很多
類似我們剛才的討論
或是說被一些
參加很多活動會被問這樣子
然後也做了很多的思考
所以說才會寫了這本書
那這本書我真的覺得
它很像是給所有成功人士
又或者說包括
有權力的人
國家的領導 有權者
應該要看
對 必須要看
因為其實這些思考
也都在這些有權者當中
不斷的縈繞著
他們也都在想
那我接下來該怎麼做
那接下來其他人會怎麼想
就是這些人想完了
我跟你說 我們大概是這樣子
我覺得裡面有一些核心的心法
是很基本的
而且我覺得這些東西
就在包括Sting最後的
這個討論裡面
因為我們必須要不斷的前進
不斷的摸索 才會走到未來
對 創造未來 走到未來
對
那今天就再次感謝Sting
然後也謝謝
我們AI創世紀這本書
帶來的機會這樣子
那我們今天的
思想實驗室就到這邊結束了
我們下集再見
掰掰 掰掰
歡迎來到思想實驗室
我是國威
思想實驗室的YouTube會員功能
今天起正式上線了
感謝大家一直以來的信任
想邀請最挺我們的你
與我們一起走得更遠
有了大家的支持
我們承諾會繼續製作
更多優質的內容
在未來與大家一起
做不同主題的思想實驗
歡迎點擊下方的加入按鈕
與我們一同前行